une petite révolution c'est ce que
promet ursula von der leyen en matière
de politique migratoire
ce mercredi la chef de l'exécutif
européen s'est exprimé devant le
parlement à bruxelles
la commission va présenter un nouveau
pacte sur la migration au coeur de celui
ci se trouve un engagement en faveur
d'un système plus européen
je peux annoncer que nous allons abolir
le règlement de dublin et le remplacer
par un nouveau système européen de
gouvernance de la migration
il aura des structures communes en
matière d'asile et de politique de
retour et il y aura un nouveau mécanisme
fort de solidarité
le règlement de dublin sera donc bientôt
aux oubliettes
cet accord qui confie le traitement des
demandes d'asile au premier pays
d'entrée dans l'union européenne
concrètement il prévoit qu'un réfugié
afghan ayant atteint l'allemagne sera
renvoyé vers le premier pays européen
qu'il a traversées pour entamer une
demande d'asile
un phénomène qui a montré ses failles en
faisant peser une pression énorme sur
les pays d'europe du sud comme l'espagne
l'italie ou la grèce
l'île de lesbos en est le parfait
exemple
porte d'entrée européenne pour des
milliers de migrants les structures
d'accueil sont littéralement saturé
lincendie du camp de moria la semaine
dernière a poussé douze mille personnes
sur les routes de l'île
hier quatre migrants ont été inculpés
devant le tribunal de lesbos ils sont
soupçonnés par le gouvernement grec
d'avoir volontairement incendié le camp
de moria un nouveau camp a été érigées à
la hâte
jusqu'à 8000 personnes devraient pouvoir
être aidées ce soir si elles viennent
car vous savez que 1100 personnes sont
actuellement dans le camp il s'agit
principalement de personnes vulnérables
des personnes qui ont été à moriat peut
venir dans ce camp et nous les
encourageons à venir parce que c'est là
que les procédures vont continuer que
des solutions peuvent être trouvées
et que les gens pourront quitter l'île
parce que l'idée n'est pas que les gens
restent pour toujours sur l'île de
lesbos quitté lesbos au plus vite
tout dépendra du nouveau plan de la
commission européenne et de son
mécanisme de solidarité
il sera dévoilé à bruxelles mercredi
prochain
autres thèmes mis en avant hier par la
présidente de la commission européenne
l'écologie on sait la vendline annoncé
la mise en place d'un pacte vert 30 % du
plan de relance européen de 750
milliards d'euros sera financée par des
mesures écologiques
la dirigeante se veut notamment plus
ambitieuse contre objectifs de réduction
de gaz à effet de serre avec une
réduction de 55 % d'ici à 2030